[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
عن طريق البريه لشحن حبوب اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الملك المغربي يغيب عن قمه الجزائر
والجامعه العربيه تامل باستعاده البلدين
الحوار
كون انه حصل بعض الامور
واستطعنا احتوائها في حدود
رياح واوروبا يمينيه وفي امريكا الجنوبيه
يساريه لولا دا سيلفا يعود لرئاسه
البرازيل وبلسونارو او ترامب الاستوائيه
صامت
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه تتابعون ايضا
الهادئ يعود للتوتر
بي 52 الى استراليا وبكينا توثيق حبل الود
والاستثمار مع الجزر
[موسيقى]
في هذه المرحله من الحرب في اوكرانيا سقطت
الكثير من المحاذير وبات قصف كل شيء مباحا
طالما يؤثر في مسار الحرب
باسلحه فائقه الدقه وكذلك منشات للقياده
العسكريه
بانه هجوما روسيا كثيفا تسبب في القطاع
المياه والكهرباء عن مناطقه واسعه
من طراز كروز اطلقت من شمال
عن 80% من المستهلكين في العاصمه وانقطاع
الكهرباء عن
350,000 منزل على الحياه صعبه
بعد كيف سيعبرون الشتاء القادم ان استمر
استنزاف سلاحي ماء الاساسيين الكهرباء
والماء
لقد توقف المترو عن العمل علمت بعدها
انفجارات طالت مواقع في حركهاف
التفاعل كما ينبغي لكنني مزعج وسئمت الامر
لن يستسلم احد بهذا الشكل انه الشهر
التاسع للحرب لقد فهم الجميع اهميه الامر
لا اعرف حتى الان كيفيه الشعور حيا لهذا
الامر
الشعور بالسوء هي لهذا الامر يجب على
الناس يذهب الى العمل كل شخص لديه مهامه
ليقوم بها لم يصل احد الى وجهتي بعد
كان هذا قلق اهالي خارقاف بالتحديد لكن
هناك قلقا يتخطى اوكرانيا قلق عالمي من
تفاقم ازمه الغذاء بعد تعليق روسيا
الاتفاق بشان صادرات الحبوب من الموانئ
الاوكرانيه
مشاركتها بهجوم مكثف بطائرات مسيره استحدث
صباح السبت سفنا عسكريه ومدنيه تابعه
للاسطول الروسي في خليجي 7
بشبه جزيره القرم واليوم قال المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه
بدا ياخذوا منحا اخر ليكون اكثر خطوره
بحسب قوله وفي اتصال مع الصحفيين امتنع
بسكوف عن التعليق بشان المطلوب من وجهه
نظري روسيا لاستئناف الاتفاق على الجهه
الاخرى اتهم الرئيس الاوكراني فولو دي
ميرسي لنسكي موسى بابتزاز العالمي بالجوع
من لتعليق اتفاق الحبوب من جانب واحد كما
دعت اوكرانيا الى ممارسه الضغط على روسيا
لدفعها للالتزام بتعهداتها بموجب الاتفاق
المبرم في يوليو الماضي الامين العام
للامم المتحده قال انه يواصل اجراء
اتصالات مكثفه لوضع حد لتعليق روسيا
مشاركتها في مبادره الحبوب واضاف ان هذه
الجهود تهدف ايضا الى تجديد وتطبيق
المبادره بشكل كامل وازاله العقبات التي
تقف في طريقي تصدير الاغذيه والاسمده
الروسيه بدوره قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي توسطت بلاده والامم المتحده
لاتمام هذا الاتفاق ان انقره ستعمل على
ايصال الحبوب للدول التي تواجه خطر
المجاعه من خلال الاليه المشتركه التي
انشئت في اسطنبول
من خلال الاليه المشتركه التي انشاناها في
اسطنبول ساعدنا في الحد نسبيا من ازمه
الغذاء من خلال اخراج تسعه ملايين
و300,000 طن من الحبوب الاوكرانيه للعالم
رغم ان روسيا متردده في هذا الموضوع لانها
تشعر وانها لا تحظى بنفس الفرص الا اننا
سنواصل بعزم جهودنا لخدمه الانسانيه
مع تعليق روسيا لصفقه الحبوب صحيفه نيورك
تايمز نقلت عن محللين لاسواق السلع قولهم
ان قرار روسيا على المدى القصير سيؤدي الى
ارتفاع اسعار الحبوب عالميه ما يضر بشكل
خاص بالبلدان التي تفقر حكوماتها الى
وسائل دعم للمواد الغذائيه الاساسيه من
بين هذه الدول الصومال وفيها قال المبعوث
الرئاسي للاستجابه للجافه عبد الرحمن عبد
الشكور انها بلاده تعتمد على اوكرانيا في
70% من وارداتها من الحبوب واضاف المسؤول
الصومالي انا انخفاض انتاج الغذاء المحلي
بسبب الجفاف الذي دام عامين واستمرار
انقطاع الحبوب من اوكرانيا يشكل ازمه
لسبعه ملايين شخص في الصومال يكافحون
بالفعل للحصول على ما يكفي من الغذاء
المشكله اكبر بحسب موريفي موتيكا مدير
برنامج افريقيا بمجموعه الازمات الدوليه
الذي قال ان التعليق صفقه الحبوب لن يسبب
مشاكل للدول الاكثر احتياجا في افريقيا
فقط لكن ايضا لدول الاكبر نتحدثنا عن جنوب
افريقيا غانا وكينيا التي تواجه حكوماتها
ضغوطا لمعالجه ارتفاع اسعار المواد
الغذائيه حتى قبل اعلان روسيا قرارا اذا
تعليق صفقه الحبوب عاده طرحه خطط الطرق
البديله لاخراج الحبوب الاوكرانيه فما
جديد هذه الخطط يا طارق
الاخبار العاجله الوارده عن المقابله التي
تجريها العربيه مع وزير خارجيه الجزائر
يتحدث عن توافق على معظم برود مشروع بيان
القمه العربيه في الجزائر والتحضيرات التي
سبقت القمه العربيه يقول وزير الخارجيه
الجزائري بشرت بنجاحها وزير الخارجيه يقول
هناك توافق كبير بشان وثيقه اعلان الجزائر
الجديد راويه وان فرنسا تحدثت اليوم عن
نقل الحبوب من اوكرانيا الى دول الجوار عن
طريق البر الخطه طرحت سابقا مع بدايه
الازمه اليوم قال وزير الزراعه الفرنسيه
مارك سنو ان بلاده تسعى الى اتاحت طرق
بريه لمرور صادرات الغذائيه من اوكرانيا
كبديل لطريق البحر الاسود الوزير الفرنسيه
اعتبر ان على الغرب العمل لايجاد طريقه لا
يخضع فيها العالم لحسني او سوانيا الرئيس
الروسيه لكن ما ابرز طرق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه التي تحدث عنها وزير الزراعه
الفرنسي الطريق الاول يمر عبر رومانيا
تنقل شحنات الحبوب برا عبر الجنوب غرب
اوكرانيا بعدها عن طريق نهر الدانوب وصولا
الى مصب النهر في مدينه سولينا ومن هناك
يتم نقل بحرا الى ميناء كونستان وبذلك
تتجاوز الشحنات الاسطوره الروسيه في البحر
الاسود الطريق الاخر طرح غربا من اوكرانيا
الى بولندا وعبره تنتقل الحبوب بل تنقل
بالقطارات لكن هذا السيناريو يواجه مشكله
تتمثل في ان السكك القطار الاوكرانيه اعرض
من نظراتها الاوروبيه ما يعني ان يتم
تفريغ الحبوب عند الحدود الاوكرانيه وثم
اعاده تحميلها على عربات قطارات الاوروبيه
في رحله تستغرق ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه اسابيع
وصولا الى موانئ بحر البطيخ
رغم التوقف المتوقع لصفقه الحبوب بعد
تعليق روسيا بشكل احادي التزاماتها قالت
اوكرانيا ان اثنتي عشره سفينه ابحرت من
موانئها اليوم محمله بكميات قياسيه متحدث
باسم الاداره العسكريه لاوديسا قال انه تم
تصديره اكثر من 300 و 54,000 طن في اكبر
كميه يتم شحنها في يوم واحد منذ توسط
تركيا والامم المتحده في ابرام اتفاق
الحبوب وقال وزير البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه وهو اوليكساندر كوبرا كوف ان
وفود الامم المتحده وتركيا
10 فرقا لتفتيش او 10 فرقه لتفتيش 40
سفينه بهدف في تنفيذ المبادره كما اعلن
الوزير ان اربع سفن اخرى سمح لها بالتوجه
الى الموانئ الاوكرانيه بعد ما خضعت
بالفعل لعمليه تفتيش من ممثلي الام
المتحده وتركيا واوكرانيا وروسيا
[موسيقى]
المعنى من باريس دكتور محمد سيف الدين
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه والمتخصص في
شان الروسيه اهلا بك معنا الدكتور
مسيناروهات الاقرب لاعتمادها باعتقادك
وفقه متابعتك ووفقا المعطيات المعلنه حتى
الساعه لاستبدال اتفاق الحبوب بعد
الاعلانات المتكرره بشان فشله
اعتقد بدايه ان الطرق البريه وطرق
السكاكيه النقل السكاكي والطرق النقل
النهري عبر عبر رومانيا ممكن ان تشكل حلا
جزئيا لهذه الازمه ولكنها لا يمكن ان تشكل
حلا على المدى الطويل
النقل البحري هو يعني يوفر امكانيه نقل
منخفض
الكلاف بشكل يعني كبير جدا
ويوفر الوقت على المصدرين وعلى المستوردين
ايضا بالنسبه لجداول
الاستلام والتسليم في هذه المسائل النقل
البري والسكك هنا يزيد من الكلف بشكل كبير
جدا يؤخر بالنسبه للوقت ويزيد من الاعباء
على الدول المستورده وعلى الدول المصدره
وتالي هو لا يتمتع بالمرونه الكافيه
بالنسبه لنقل كميات كبيره من هذه
التنازل
طاقه ولا قبل مواد غذائيه يبدو انه اثر
على الغرب لتغيير موقفه حتى دول المتضرره
من كل ذلك هل تعتقد فيها في هذه نعم
في هذه اللحظه في هذه اللحظه من المواجهه
يعني تستخدم موسكو الان الاوراق المتنوعه
التي اكتسبتها خلال الاشهر الماضيه والتي
وفرتها براي لهذه اللحظه هي قننت بشكل
كبير جدا باستخدام هذا النوع من ال- من
الاوراق وكان هذا مادار نقاش داخلي في
موسكو في صحافه الروسيه وفي الصالون
السياسي الروسي بانه لماذا يعني يطرح
السؤال لماذا لم تضرب موسكو مثلا من
الاسابيع الاولى البنا التحتيه بشكل كامل
ولم تستخدم كل قدرتها على على القصف يعني
في هذا المكان يعني هناك تحليلات بان بان
الابقاء على هذه يعني على هذا على هذه
الامكانات هو لتقنينه واستخدامه في مرحله
جديد الذي ستقدمه باريس يعني فرنسا تحاول
ان تجد حلا همم المسارات البريه معايير
قضبان القطارات غير متوافقه بين اوكرانيا
وغيرها من الدول النقل عبر البر فيه مخاطر
عديده يؤثر على الفاقد وايضا على صلاحيه
احيانا الحبوب والاهم عامل الامان يعني من
يضمن هذه
الشحنات ان لا تتعرض للقذف المباشر من
القوات الروسيه ان لم نقل بشكل مقصد ربما
بالخطا
يعني الان تقوم الامم المتحده وتركيا
بالاستمرار في موضوع الاتفاق لكن بالضبط
ما اشرت اليه هو الاهم في هذه المساله
عندما لا توفر موسكو الامن او يعني القدره
على حمايه هذه السفن العابره عبر البحر
الاسود فبالتاكيد سوف ترتفع كفتها من
ناحيه التامين وبالتالي فانها لن تكون
ممكن ان يعني تسير في هذا الاتجاه اعتقد
ان المبادره الفرنسيه في هذا الشان يمكن
ان يكون الخط المار عبر رومانيا وعبر
النهر يعني اقل كلفه من الخط البري
بالكامل الذي يمكن ان يمر عبر بولندا الى
شواطئ همم دول دول البلطيق لكن هذا اقول
مره جديده يعني هو تعبير عن رفض القوه
الغربيه وتحديدا على الاوروبيه وفرنسا
بالدرجه الاولى ليه يعني وسائل الضغط
الروسيه والاستمرار بالموقف بشكل متين
والقول لاوكرانيا بان هذا النوع من الضغط
لن يثمر وبالتالي يعني استمرار في الموقف
الاوروبي في العام الاوكرانيا
محمد نعم الجانب التركي هل يمكن ان يؤثر
بشكل ايجابي من جديد على الموقف الروسي
ويحرك
الان الموقف التركي من موضوع روسيا لافت
جدا ويجب بحثه بشكل دقيق جدا الان تركيا
تتغير يعني يتغير دور تركيا بالنسبه
لروسيا تتحول تركيا بشكل متزايد الى مركز
تصدير الغاز الروسي وهذا الامر يتم العمل
عليه بشكل متسارع جدا وخلال الاسابيع
الماضيه كان هناك يعني العديد من اللقاءات
بين الرئيسين الروسي والتركي ايضا اذا
نظرنا يعني باتجاه الشرق الى ازمه ارمينيا
او اذربيجان ايضا هناك يعني تفعيل للدور
الروسي التركي المشترك ويحاولون صياغه
موقف موحد من هذا الامر والان في هناك قمه
في صوت شيخ حول هذه المساله ما اريد قوله
في هذا الشان بان الموقف التركي بالعلاقه
مع موسكو في الحرب الاوكرانيه ايضا يتاثر
بالدوري التركي الجديد الذي تريد موسكو
يعني تعذيذه وبالتالي يمكن ان تساعد تركيا
على يعني اخراج اتفاق ما في هذا الشان لكن
ما يضغط بالاتجاه المعاكس بان التفاصيل
الميدانيه والمعارك لا تزداد المحتدمه على
الارض القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا يعني دي
مستمره بمحاوله يعني قدم كميات كبيره من
الاراضي قبل حلول الشتاء بشكل قاسي جدا
القوات الروسيه تحاول الصمود واستغلال فصل
الشتاء لتعود في فصل الربيع وبالتالي
الضغوط الميدانيه مستمره بشكل كبير لتعارك
هذا الامر وسنتابع هذا الموضوع معكم شكرا
جزيلا لك من باريس دكتور محمد سيف الدين
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه والمتخصص في
الشان الروسي تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
اذا ااه عديد همم تصريحات الوارده عن وزير
الخارجيه الجزائري في المقابله مع العربيه
بعد المقابله التي اجرتها العربيه ايضا مع
وزير الخارجيه المغربي وسنتطرق اليها بعد
قليل وزير خارجيه الجزائر للعربيه شغلنا
الشاغل بناء توافقات بين دول العربيه وتم
استقبال كافه وزراء الخارجيه العرب بالمثل
دون تمييز ولم يحدث اي خلاف مع عناصر حول
ادانه التدخلات التركيه يضيف ايضا الوزير
الجامعه العربيه تعترف في خريطه واحده
للعالم العربي دون حدود ايضا رئيس تونس
اعتبر بانه كان سيستقبل العاجل المغربي
اذا همم حضر وايضا بانه همم
نحترم قرار العاهل المغربي بعد عدم
المشاركه في هذه القمه
في المغرب العربي ولكن نحترم قرار المغرب
اذا قادت الدول العربيه بداوا اليوم
بالتوافد على الجزائر للمشاركه في اعمال
القمه العربيه الحاديه والثلاثين المجمع
عقدها غدا الثلاثاء
لصياغه بنود مشروع بيان القمه هذا وتعد
قمه الجزائر هي الاولى منذ ثلاث سنوات
[موسيقى]
الان ان هدفنا من القمه العربيه هو ان
تكون لم الشمل مثل ما هو العنوان اكد
الامين العام للجامعه العربيه حسام زكي
للعربيه ان قمه الجزائر ستعيد التاكيد على
رفض تدخلات تركيا وايران وسدد زكي على
ادانت التدخلات الايرانيه كافه في المنطقه
واعرب عن عمله في ان تتجاوب المغرب
والجزائر مع جهود الحوار
لا نريد
القمه في حد ذاتها تكون
يعني مسار للخلاف هي بالعكس هي المفروض
وانامل كنا جميعا انها تكون
[موسيقى]
هي دافع للالتقاء والحوار
كون انه حصل بعض الامور
واستطعنا احتوائها في حينه بالفعل
لكن بالنهايه همم هذه قرارات دول وقرارات
قاده وهمم جلاله الملك اتخذ قراره بنعرف
وثيقه بكل التطورات التي حدثت همم
يعني انا عاده لا افقد الامل ايه
والدبلوماسيه هكذا لا يجب ان تفقد الامل
من جهه اخرى
للعربيه انه يتعذر على العاهل المغربي
حضور القمه العربيه للاعتبارات اقليميه
اكد في المقابله التي اجرتها زميله ميسون
عزام واعطى تعليمات للوفد بالعمل البنائي
رغم عدم حضوره
الجزائر بشان ازمه الخريطه لم تكن مقنعه
وان القمه العربيه حدث رئيسي لكنها لا
تختزلوا العمل العربيه المشتركه
التدخل في شؤون الدول يجب ان يسود اضاف
بوريطه ان ثلثي وفد الاعلامي وصل الجزائر
وعد من المطار لسبب غير واضح
امس اخبارنا الجامعه العربيه بانه يتعذر
على جلاله الملك حضور اشغال القمه كان
جلاله الملك محمد السادس من اول القضاء
عن استعدادهم لحضور هذا القمه
وكان جلاله الملك
حتى تعليمات
الدول العربيه عن استعداد جلاله الملك
للقيام بهذه السياره للحضور القمه وتشجيعز
يعني هذا العرب على القيام بذلك
جلاله الملك
الاشغال ولكن جلاله الملك عنده اعتبارات
مرتبطه
سياق اقليمي ثنائي وغيره
كنت
بان يعني المغرب ما يكونش الدوله الوحيده
لتلتي الوفد الاعلامي وصل وعاد بدون ما
يقوم بالتغطيه
سالت بعد الزملاء يعني ما كانش 12 ل 12
يعني فيها من المصور والمكياج وكل شيء
همم كان يوم مصدر
هيئه الصحفي المغاربه واش احنا ضروري هذا
واش ضروري مثل هذا نضيعوا الطاقه
يتم التعامل معها بشكل اخر
ونضم الينا من الجزائر مفاضه العربيه
محمود الورواري اهلا بك محمود يعني هناك
حديث لفت لوزير الخارجيه الجزائريه
للعربيه يتحدث فيها عن عده نقاط من ضمنها
العلاقات مع المغرب هل من جديد سجل او
اختراق في هذا الخلاف بين الجزائر والمغرب
العربيه الحقيقه ان السؤال الابرز طوال
الثلاثه ايام الماضيه وهو يدور حول هل
تنجح هذه القمه في تحقيق شعارها المتعلق
بلم الشمل وتحديدا لم الشمل الجزائري
المغربي جاءت الاجابه على شاشه العربيه
تحديدا من خلال اللقاءات او تصريحات من
وزير الخارجيه المغربي ووزير الخارجيه
الجزائري بانه للاسف لم يحدث ذلك يعني ما
زالت الخلافات قائمه وان الوضع ما زال كما
كان قائما قبل هذه القمه يعني ما زال
الجليد قائم في العلاقات العلاقات ما زالت
متوتره واضح انه الجامعه العربيه قالت كل
هذا يعني السفير حسام زكي من عمل مساعد
تحدي على ان هذا شان يخص المغرب له
احترامه وشان يخص الجزائر هذا احترامه
الجامعه العربيه حا لكنها يعني لم تتوصل
لصيغه تذويب الجليد في هذا الملف هذا
الملف الابرز والاجوبه جاءت على شاشه
العربيه لكن هناك ملفات اخرى وهناك عناوين
اخرى وما زالت عيون مصلطه على البيان
الختامي الذي سنتابعه بعد غدا تحديدا جدول
حافل خلال اليومين الماضيين والجديد
سيتعلق ببندين رئيسيين البند الاول هو
يتعلق بالصياغه النهائيه التي كلنا توقعنا
او جاءت تسريبات ايضا للعربيه على الصياغه
النهائيه في بلده تدخلات في شؤون العربيه
والبند المتعلق ب فلسطين راويه همم محمود
وزير خارجيه الجزائر قبل قليل يضيف
للعربيه ان الرئيس [__] اكد لنا اننا لن
نقبل المساس بامن دول الخليج وان العلاقات
مع السعوديه ممتازه ونعتمد على دعم
المملكه همم قويه هناك عديد من الدول
الغير الممثله همم براس الهرم فيها هل
يعني كيف اثر ذلك وهل يمكن ان يؤثر على
البيان الختام على وثيقه اعلان الجزاء
موسيقى اعلان الجزائر طاهر انت تعلم جيدا
انه البيانات الختاميه هي بيانات ثابته
يتم التغيير كل عام في الصيغات وهذا بند
مهم جدا ليعود الى ميثاق الام جامعه الدول
العربيه التي صيغه عام خمسه او 1945 في
الاسكندريه انه اذا همم تلتزم بالبنود
الدول التي وفقت عليها وبالتالي اذا وقعت
همم وقع القاده على البيان فهو بمثابه
التزام بالنسبه له البند الذي كان اخذ
كثير من التجاذبات فيما يتعلق بالصياغه هو
بند التدخلات الاجنبيه كان هناك مطالبات
بان يكون هناك تصريح وتسميه صريحه لدولتين
ايران وتركيا بسبب التدخلات في العالم
العربي ما وصلنا وصلنا انتظر ايضا البيان
هذا تسريب وصلنا بانه اعتمدت الصياغات
السابقه ما هي الصيغه السابقه في هذا
البنك طاهر هي
خدوا الدول مستمعه كل التدخلات الاجنبيه
في الشان العربي بما ينقص من سيادتها الذي
اضيف حسب علمنا هذا يعني هذا هذه القمه
انه الوجود الاجنبي ايضا يعني نرفض
التدخلات الخارجيه من اللجوء من الاجانب
والوجود الاجنبي في الدول العربيه هذه
اشاره الى ليبيا كما تعرف بسبب التواجدات
الاجنبيه الموجوده في ليبيا لكن هذا البند
حسن عليه توافق كبير الان لانه هذا اليوم
كان يوم صعب كان في تجاوبات وفي زيارات
ولقاءات مكوكيه لم تكن معلنه للاعلام في
اطار الوصول الى بيان الجزائر في هذه
القمه العاديه المهمه جدا باقي عنوان مهم
جدا وهو عنوان فلسطين ربما يكون لو لديكم
وقت نتحدث فيه تفضل لعل انا متابع فيه
نشراتنا اللاحقه وفي الايام اللاحقه ايضا
همم مفرد العربيه محمود الورواري الى
الجزائر العربيه شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات تحياتي
العربيه 360 ايضا
الصين من المزاحمه على زعامه الارض الى
المزاحمه على رياده الفضاء القصر السماوي
في طريقه للاكتماره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تتواصلوا احتفالات انصار
الرئيس البرازيلي المنتخب لولا سلفا
بالفوز بينما تواصلت التهاني من مختلف
قاده وزعماء العالم
انه يتطلع الى العمل معه لمواصله التعاون
بين البلدين وصدر الموقف نفسه عن موسكو مع
اعلان الرئيس
في مواصله تنميه التعاون المشترك في مختلف
المجلات
في دفع العلاقات بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
والبرازيل الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
سيلفا يفتحوا صفحه جديده في تاريخ
البرازيل
لكن بعد هذه التهاني ما يزال امام الرئيس
المهزوم بولسونارو جي يير بورتسونارو
شهران في الحكم شهران قد يحدث فيهما
الكثير والكثير
لم يخيل للطفل لولا الذي خرج من فقر
بيرنان بوكو المتوقع ان يصبح رئيسا رئيسا
لبلاده الشاسعه البرازيل لولايتين
متتاليتين والثالثه اليوم الا اذا الا اذا
ماذا اذا قرر خصمه اليمني والرئيس الحالي
المنتهيه ولايهته جايه يربوط سونارو عدم
الاعتراف بهزيمته في الانتخابات فالرجل
يلتزم الصمت حتى الان صمت سونار يثير
مخاوف من ان يفي بالاسم الذي اطلقه عليه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الذي
لقبه بالترامب الاستوائيه لتذهب البلاد
لمعضله سياسيه
لويس
سونارو بفارق بسيط في الدوره الثانيه
نتحدث عن
49.1% من الاصوات للخاسر مقابل 50 فاصل
تسعه بالمئه للربح ليواجه مهمات جسيمه
ابرزها توحيد توحيد بلد عرف باداره مطربه
خلال ولايه سلفه على مدى اربع سنوات وسببت
انقساما نتيجه اكثر الحملات استقطابا في
تاريخ البرازيل الحديث لكن الرئيس المنتخب
الخارج من صفوف فقراء الشمال الشرقي
للبرازيل يرى انه لا توجد دوله برازيليه
مقسمه بل يوجد شعب واحد توجد امه واحده
للدوله العميقه كما توصف الا انه تعهد بان
يكون رئيسا للجميع
[موسيقى]
رانيا في الدم
صوت ضد سيلفا 58 مليون برازيليه عدد ليس
بالقليل الان عليه ايضا ان يتعايش مع
برلمان يميل اكثر الى اقصى اليمين بينما
يقود لولا دا سيلفا تلافا غير متجانس من
حوالي 10 احزاب حول حزب العمال كذلك اختار
النائب رئيس وسطيا وهو جيرالدو الكمين
خصمه السابق المهزوم في انتخابات 2006
الرئاسيه اذا اختار خصمه
السابقين واوصات الاعمال المعتدله عوده
لولا دا سيلفا الى السلطه تعطينا املا
كبيرا الكلام لممثله عن السكان الاصليين
الامل هنا بالعوده الى منطقه امازون نابضه
الحياه بعد ان اضعفها بشده خفض الائتمان
وافلات المهربين التام من العقاب وفي هذه
النقطه تحديدا يقول الرئيس المنتخب ان
البرازيل مستعده لاستعاده زعامتها في
مكافحه ازمه المناخ
البرازيل بحاجه كما كوكب الارض الى منطقه
امازون متعافيه لكن التحدي الكبير الاخر
الذي يواجه الرئيس القديم الجديد يتمثل في
تراجع الموارد الماليه للدوله راويه خاصه
وبشكل كبير بعد خاصه بعد توزيع الرئيس
المنتهى ولايته المليارات من
العملات المحليه لمساعده الاغراض
الانتخابيه الخاصه بها قبل ان يعني نتابع
بهذا الموضوع اعلام امريكي يتحدث بانه
الماسك يحل مجلس اداره قطر
اذا مشاهدينا رغم ذلك الامل بالرئيس
المنتخب يبدو كبيرا ليس داخليا فقط بل
عالميا نتحدث امريكيا روسيا صينيا اوروبيا
والاهم توسع المد الوردي في امريكا
اللاتينيه تسير رياح القاره اللاتينيه عكس
تيار التشدد العالمي الذي يشد البلاد
والعباد هناك نحو اليمين في اوروبا خصوصا
فا زعماء المد الوردي في القاره اللاتينيه
هنا واحتفلوا بالرئيس البرازيلي المنتخب
لان انتخابه يصب في صالح تعزيز الزعماء
اليساريين في المنطقه فمع انتصار لولا على
اليمني بولسوا ناره تنضم البرازيل الى كل
من كولومبيا والمكسيك والارجنتين وتشيلي
وبيرو في كتله يسريه متنانيه وصف المد
الوردي استخدم للمره الاولى لوصف موجه من
الحكومات اليساريه التي ظهرت في اوائل
العقد الاولي من القرن الحادي والعشي
لتتحول هذه الدول على مدى سنوات العشر
التاليه الى اليمين لكن وبعد فشل التجربه
اليمنيه وتفشي التضخم وتاثير رائحه كورونا
قرر الناخبون المحبط في امريكا اللاتينيه
بعدها التخلي عن الاحزاب الحاكمه واتباع
التعهدات بزياده الانفاق الاجتماعي نقصد
هنا العوده نحو اليسار كتب جوستافو باترو
همم الذي تم انتخابه في يونيو الماضي كاول
رئيس يسري لكولومبيا على تويتر يعيش لولا
بينما كتب الرئيس
مبروك يا اخي انتصاركم يقوي الديمقراطيه
والاندماج في امريكا اللاتينيه وقال
الرئيس الفنزويلي نيكولاس مادورو انتصرت
الديمقراطيه اليوم في البرازيل يتبقى
اليوم ان يحقق المد الوردي اما لا نخبي به
ويحول حياتهم الى الوان ورديه مبهجه خصوصا
ان لولا ده سيلفا في ولاياتيه السابقتين
بين العامين الفين وثلاثه و 2010 نجح
بانتشال 30 مليون نسمه من البؤس حينها
شكرا قوي
[موسيقى]
التوتر بين الولايات المتحده والصين في
منطقه المحيط الهادي قد يزيدوا معدله بعد
انباء اعلنتها استراليا هيئه الاذاعه
الاستراليه قالت اليوم ان الولايات
المتحده تعتزم ارسال ما يصل الى 6 قاذفات
قنابل من طراز بي 502 القادره على حمل
اسلحه نوويه الى قاعده تندل الجويه
الاستراليه ونقل عن سلاح الجو الامريكي
نقل قوله ان القدره على نشرته بعيده المدى
في استراليا تبحث رساله قويه للخصوم ارسلت
الولايات المتحده هذا العام اربع طائرات
به 502 الى قاعده اندرسون الجويه في جزيره
غوام متابعه للولايات المتحده بدوره قال
رئيس الوزراء
ان القوات الامريكيه تقوم بزياره
لاستراليا خاصه لمدينه داروين التي يتركز
فيها عناصر من مشاهده البحريه الامريكيه
على جانب الاخر تحاول الصين توسيعه قاعده
تحالفاتها في المحيط الهادئ
وقتا يستمر فيه الدعم المالي من بكين
للمنطقه بالانفاق قالت صحيفه ديكارديان
البريطانيه ان الصين تسعى لمواجهه الدعم
الوارد لجزر المحيط من دول مثل تايوان على
سبيل المثال قدم التايوان ما بين ثمانيه
الى تسعه ملايين دولار سنويا لما يسمى
بصناديق تنميه الدوائر الانتخابيه في جزر
سليمان بينما اسهمت الصين بمبلغ يصل الى
احد 10 مليون دولار وبشكل عام تراجعت
مساعده الصين لمنطقه المحيط الهادئ من
2007 مليون دولار عام 2016 الى نحو 180
مليون قبل عامين في وقت لم تتوفر فيه
ارقام العمل الماضي
اضافت ان المساعده الصينيه تظل اداه
دبلوماسيه الرئيسيه لبكين في المحيط
الهادئ وتحديدا في سليمان وكيري باتي نقلت
الصحيفه عن مسؤولين قولهم ان الصين زادت
من حجم الاستثمار في البنيه التحتيه لدعم
استضافه جزر سليمان لدوره العاب المحيط
الهادئ العمل المقبل واصفين استثمارات
الصين في جزر سليمان بانها صغيره لكنها
تتزايد بسرعه وعلى الرغم من قله رقم
الاستثمارات الصينيه الا ان البكين تسعى
لتركيز نفوذها في الجزر التي غيرت ولاءها
الدبلوماسيه من تايبي الى بيكي
[موسيقى]
وان اتابع واياكم في العربيه 360 ايضا
في اوكرانيا ما انسب مكان تحت فيه من قصف
احفاد الصوفيات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
باعتبارها قوه عالميه تنافس على الزعامه
وليس الحضور الدوليه فقط
العملاق الاسيوي المرحله الثالثه والاخيره
لبناء محطته الفضائيه الخاصه مرحله من
شانها السماح بتشغيل محطه
الفضائيه او القصر السماوي بالكامل
وجودا دائما في الفضاء مع اطلاق الجزء
المسمى
او حلم السماوات بواسطه صاروخ لون ماركت 5
بي من جزيرتنان المداريه جنوب الصين
من هو الجزء الثالث والاخير الرئيسي لمحطه
تيانج كونج التي تتخذ شكل حرف تي باللغه
الانجليزيه
واحتاج تجميع المحطه الى احد 10 مهمه
فضائيه صينيه في ابريل من عام 2021 بدات
الصين في انشاء محطتها الفضائيه باطلاق
الوحده وهي مقر المعيشه الرئيس لرواد
الفضاء وفي يوليو من عام 2022 اطلقت
الوحده
او الانطلاق الى السماوات وهي وحده وحده
مختبر تجرى فيها التجارب العلميه ومن
المتوقع ان تلتحهم وهي وحده مختبر ايضا
ويبلغ وزنها 23 طنا
بمنفذ محور من طرف من تيانخا اليوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المحطه والصينيه ستبقى على مدار منخفض
يتراوح بين
450 كلم فوق الارض لمده 10 سنوات على
الاقل مع هدف معلن بالمحافظه على وجود
بشري طويل الامد في الفضاء ومع ان الصين
لا تتوقع تعاونا دوليا بشان محطتها
الفضائيه الا انها اكدت انفتاحها على
التعاون مع اطراف اجنبيه ورغم دخولها
السباق الفضائي متاخره الا انها اثبتت
قدرات كبيره في المجال طموح بكين الفضائي
تعزز برفدي واشنطن مشاركتها في برنامج
محطه الفضاء الدوليه التي تتعاون في
اطارها الولايات المتحده وروسيا وكندا
واوروبا واليابان فقررت الذهاب منفردتا
ارسلت الصين اول رائد فضاء لها الى الفضاء
عام 2003
واطلقت عام 2019 مركبه حطت على الجانب
من القمر في سابقه عالميه في عام 2020
نقلت الصين عينات من القمر واطلقت كذلك
مسبارا صغيرا الى المريخ كما تنوي ارسال
رواد فضاء الى القمر بحلول عام 2003 اذا
طموح كبير عزز التاثير الايجابي والمعنوي
على الصين لتظهر باعتبارها قوه عالميه
تحاول المنافسه على زعامه العالم وليس
الوجود بين الكبار فقط على ما يبدو
[موسيقى]
اظهر استطلاع راي صحيفه نيويورك
عن بنسلفانيا وهو جون فطرمان بخمسه نقاط
المئويه على المرشح الجمهوري محمد
49% من الناخبين يؤيدون فترمان فيما يؤيد
نحو
44% محمد
[موسيقى]
نورسين سنايبر
سوبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يخوض الجمهوريون الانتخابات الحاليه وهم
يتهمون الرئيس بيدن والديمقراطيين بالتسبب
بالغلاء وارتفاع مؤشرات التضخم
ميدانيه للعربيه بولايه بنسلفانيا تحدثنا
فيها الى اصحاب الاعمال الصغيره عن تاثير
التضخم على سير اعمالهم والمفاجئ انهم
يعانون اكثر من ندره اليد العامله
التفاصيل مع بيان غانم
ته اهتماماتهم بنسبه 77% وكل ما اشترى
الناخبون وقودا او سلعا من المحلات يشعر
ان الاسعار ارتفع واستغل الجمهوريون الامر
وبضعوه في صلب حملتهم الانتخابيه خلال هذه
الجوله الميدانيه في مدربانيا سالنا اصحاب
المطاعم والمحلات التجاريه عن سير الاعمال
وسماعنا كلاما مختلفه صاحب هذا المطعم في
حارسبر يقول ان العمل جيد
جدا كان افضل قبل الجائحه ولكننا نعود الى
الحركه التي كانت من قبل
المثير للملاحظه ان صاحب مقهى اخر في
درسبرج بن سيلفينيا اشار الى الامر الذاتي
والرايان يتناقضان مع حمله الجمهوريين في
الانتخابات الحاليه
خفضنا ساعه العمل كثيرا ولدينا عمال اقل
ولكن على الرغم من خفض ساعات التشغيل الا
ان الدخله جيد
المثير اكثر في هذه المساله عن اصحاب
المقاهي والمطاعم يعانون من ندره اليد
العامله وطلب العمال
الوضع وليس سيئه ويمكن ان يكون افضل ولكن
الامور ليست سيئه
وبين رساله الجمهوريين للناخبين باختيار
مرشحين يرفعون عنهم اعباء موجه الغلاء
ورساله الديمقراطيين بان الرئيس بيدن يقوم
بكل ما في وسعه لمواجهه مشكله لم يتسبب
بها يبدو اصحاب الاعمال غير اكيدين من
تصويبهم وربما يريدون الابتعاد قليلا عن
النقاش السياسيه المرسوب
مثل ضبط الاسعار وشؤون التوظيف ما نريده
ان يتركونا كي ندير مصالحنا بحسب السوق
الغلاء مشكله ضربت الاقتصاد الامريكي منذ
اكثر من عام ويحاول الجمهوريون ان يقولوا
ان هذه المشكله تسبب بها الديمقراطيون
ولكن حتى الان اصحاب المحلات الصغيره لا
يعتبرون ان هذه المساله هي مشكله كبيره
[موسيقى]
في السودان تمسك تحالف الحريه والتغيير
برؤيته الهادفه الى استعاده الحكم المدني
الديمقراطيه كما رفضت مجموعه التوافق على
الوطنيه
واكدت انها ستقوم بها الزمتها
الطريق الى حل للازمه السياسيه في السودان
لا يبدو معبدا بخيارات كثيره على الفاعلين
في المشهد السياسي تحالف الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي اختتم مؤتمره سياسي معلنا
للتمسك برؤيته وقطع بعدم وجود تسويه
ثنائيه وانما عمليه سياسيه تشمل جميع قوى
الثوره والانتقال
يعني بيقول انه الحريه التغيير ثاني ليه
اتفاق ثنائي يعيد الحبوب طبعا هذه تذوب
العمليه السياسيه التي تتبناها الحريه
والحريه والتغيير وتريدها هي اعلنت مرارا
انها تتطلب يعني قاعده واسعه بالقوه
الثوره ومن قوه الانتقال
وعلى ضفه الاخرى ترى مجموعه التوافق
الوطني ان العوده الى الشراكه الثنائيه
السابقه ستتهزم بحسب تغريده للامين العام
لمجموعه التوافق الوطني
الجبهه الثوريه او كما يعرف بشركاء السلام
تتمسك باتفاقيه جوبا من جانب وتقول انها
مستعده للتنازل من جانب الاخر
للحوار الايجابي احنا نتعاطى معه وما
عندنا مشكله وممكن نقدم همم اي تنازل ناس
شايفين في مصلحه البلد
[موسيقى]
ومع الانقسامات السياسيه يبقى هنالك طرف
فاعل الذي يتمثل بالشارع المتظاهر ضد
التسويه الذي يبحث عن اهدافه بحكومه مدنيه
وقد اصدر جدولا تصعيديا لشهر نوفمبر يشمل
تظاهرات ومواكب عديده
الباحث لحل للازمه السياسيه في السودان
يدرك صعوبه المهمه فالكل هنا لا يريد
للسودان ان ينزلق الى المربع الاسود
سياسيا واقتصاديا وامنيا لقاءات الاليه
الثلاثيه والرباعيه حتى الان لم تستطع
الوصول الى نقطه الوفاق وان بشرت من قبل
ذلك محمد عثمان العربيه الخضر شكرا لعبد
الله صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 تحت وابل
من القصف الروسيه فقدت محطات المترو في
كير وظيفتها الاساسيه
لتوصيل الى ملجا مؤقت للهاربين من
الانفجارات
الى المشروع العملاق الذي بناه اجدادهم
صواريخها باطشه فان جدران ما شيدته قويه
بما فيه الكفايه كي تتحمل
وفي تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 راويه
في اطار جوله الاولى من الاستغناءات
التصريح نقلا عن واشنطن
مصر قام بحل مجلس اداره تويتر
واسود تويتر لن يبقى ابدا كما كان قبل
فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 حفل خاص
بموسوعه غينيس لتسجيل رقم قياسي جديد حضره
تاناكو هيرو كازو
واحدا بل من خلال
178 هيرو كازو تناكه هذا هو السر اذن هذا
اكبر تجمع من نوعه لاشخاص يحملون الاسم
ذاته والرقم السابق كان مسجلا لصالح 164
امراه حملنا اسم مارتنر
الى اجتهاد بالتاكيد كان اسمه ايضا هيروكا
هذا الاسم الصحيح كان مقلوب
على اسمها لتسلم الجائزه اي تناكه
تسلم الجائزه احمد